you're an interesting case study because
you're one of the most famous one of the
most uh charismatic successful humans in
the world there's a lot millions of
people love you hang on every one of
your words
that's a hard place to be
how do you call yourself how do you
admit
that you've been living a lie
how do you admit yourself in big ways
and small ways on lies at this point
given how many people love you how
famous you are
10 years ago I don't know
I I don't know someone was talking about
like
yeah they really admire this so-and-so
person because they're not someone who
looks in the mirror
and I was like yeah
also I was like
man I gotta catch myself looking in the
mirror a lot
and then I go in and I you know look at
my my wife's side of her bathroom
how many
favorite creams and stuff she has out
there look at my side I got a lot more
on my side I'm like oh
I noticed how if I'm out and the public
working out maybe doing push-ups and
maybe I do a few more if
there's a group of people walking by
that maybe I'd like to impress and I may
do a few more than I do if I was on my
own I'm like
you are vain McConaughey
yeah and the knee jerk is oh vanity bad
but and also I was like
all of a sudden I became a bullshitter
once I admitted and then I was like well
Bravo vanity yeah let's go vanity
let's instead of putting it in the
cupboard
in the LIE section oh minimum vein
because I said that's a debit no
admit it
and then go what's the value in it well
I can look it yeah it actually got in
better shape because of my vanity
actually I eat better
the better and that morning you know and
that led to being a better
better husband better dad
doing something with my kids when I'd
rather be over there writing this work
I'm working on but I know that
tomorrow
early when they leave town they're gonna
remember this time that we had together
that's a selfish act to go spend that
time with my kids or my even though I'd
rather not be doing it at that time I'd
rather I'd be doing something for myself
because when they leave tomorrow they've
got they'll have this great memory that
they spent with their dad right before
they went that that
I could call that vanity
I could group that
and say that's very vain of you that was
for self
yeah
because it
was also for something and someone that
I cared about are there people in your
life that
uh call you on your in the bad
sense the Lord yeah yeah
sometimes it's either I got a pretty
thick threshold for how far I can go
with my
like what
bruise what tickles me might bruise
others to watch it
that's a good line
yeah
um tickles me my bruise others but I
also I go back and
talk about the
that's over there with those mystical
successes
it's the yeah no no go with it
don't pull a parachute yet let's see how
far we can go let's see how hot it can
get let's try it one more time yes two
more please
that's where a lot of great pleasure and
stories and successes will come from
those are mystical they don't add up
it's like we're not talking about reason
right now we're not talking logic just
go with this let's talk about the
virtual
and making it real the old line of fake
it till you make it I mean what is that
there's something to that
there's definitely something to it
but I would you know where people would
go fake it as I would go back to
Dillinger and create it yeah recreate it
create and recreate it
you know until you till it becomes
till you make it
um so I'll have people call my
and a lot of times they're right
I think
when I handled the most healthy way is I
admit yes
and
I'm aware
so I'm and I'm going to keep going
so you're not like resisting you're
denying it oh I will I will and I have
to watch that where I'm like
no I'm not that's not what I'm doing and
and usually when it's coming from people
that are going no you are it took I
won't admit it and then that's where I'm
telling a lie
and that'll come up get me later and
I'll go
I didn't see it I didn't see I was doing
that
I was
either unaware wouldn't let myself be
aware I was denying that I was doing
that